bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct de la salle des conférences du
Sénat pour la séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement séance
présidée aujourd'hui par le
vice-président du Sénat Claude Berry Deb
qui remplace Gérard Larcher Gérard
Larcher qui est à la clôture du Congrès
des mairres Porte de Versailles à Paris
pour écouter le discours du premier
ministre manuel Vals discours bien
entendu très attendu par les élus locaux
que représente le Sénat donc cette
séance des questions d'actu va commencer
dans quelques instants sur notre antenne
avec des questions autour de
l'application de la loi Florange des
questions sur les finances locales des
questions également autour de la
pollution de l'air après l'étude publié
cette semaine par R parif et puis
également des questions autour sur
pardon les décrocheurs scolaires voilà
alors parmi les les ministres qui sont
présents cet après-midi pour répondre au
sénateur il y a Jean-Marie Louen
ministre chargé des Relations avec le
Parlement il y a également le ministre
des Finances Michel Sapin qui va
répondre notamment à une question sur
les finances locales question qui
intéresse beaucoup les sénateurs en ce
moment Carole Delga qui représente
Emmanuel Macron qui est au Congrès des
Maires également cet après-midi l' désir
chargé des affaires européennes est bien
présent dans l'hémicycle du Sénat cet
après-midi donc vous voyez pas grand
monde sur les bandes du gouvernement
parce que traditionnellement et bien le
gouvernement répond présent à l'appel de
l'organisation des maires de France pour
assister à cette clôture du Congrès des
maires en direct en même temps et bien
que cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Sénat autour donc du
discours de Manuel Vals et du nouveau
président des maires de France qui est
également sénateur François baron
parmi les autres thèmes qui vont être
abordés cet après-midi par les sénateurs
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat et bien il y
aura une question de la sénatrice
socialiste Claudine Lepage sur les
violences faites aux femmes et c'est
Pascale Boitard la secrétèire d'État
chargée des droits de femmes qui est
assez active sur cette question qui lui
répondra et puis à noter que beaucoup de
maires sont présents au Sénat cette
semaine à l'occasion de leur congrès et
ils sont présents également dans
l'hémicycle dans les tribunes des
visiteurs
pour assister à cette séance des
questions d'actualité qui est toujours
intéressante à suivre à la fois pour les
téléspectateurs et pour les visiteurs
ici au Sénat le Sénat qui est installé
dans cette grande salle des conférences
qui est à côté de de l'hémicycle des
standes pour accueillir les différents
maire cette semaine pour leur faire
comprendre un petit peu et bien comment
fonctionne la haute assemblée qui je
vous le rappelle une nouvelle fois et
bien représente les
collectivités territoriales et chargé
vraiment de suivre très spécifiquement
ces différentes thématiques donc des
maires qui sont assez présents vous
verrez peut-être sans doute autour de
nous après la séance des questions
d'actualité après cette séance on
reviendra ici en plateau dans la salle
des conférences avec nos invités nous
aurons Roger carucci le sénateur UMP des
hautes scènes pour parler bien sûr et
bien de l'élection interne à l'UMP
samedi et puis ensuite nous aborderont
le dossier des collectivités
territoriales avec l'échec tout à
l'heure à l'Assemblée nation
de la commission mixte paritaire qui
réunit sénateurs et députés pour se
mettre d'accord autour du texte sur la
délimitation des régions donc nous de
différents thèmes mais pour l'instant
voilà la séance commence on rejoint
l'hémicycle du Sénat pour ces questions
d'actualité à tout àheureur Jean reier
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames mieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
messieurs les ministres de la Défense et
des Affaires étrangères et fait suite au
nouveau report de la livraison à la
Russie du porte hélicoptère d'assaut de
type
Mistral la situation est connue de tous
mais personne ne peut dire aujourd'hui
qu'elle en sera l'issue et pas
d'avantage quand elle interviendra
surtout qu'elle dépend du conflit en
Ukraine et pourtant il faudra bien en
sortir tant les enjeux sont importants y
compris pour notre pays
mardi monsieur le Président de la
République a donc décidé jusqu'à nouvel
ordre de suspendre la livraison du
Vladivostock le premier des deux navires
Mistral commandé par la Russie en
invoquant un cage site de forces majeur
pour tenir compte semble-t-il de la
dégradation de la situation en Ukraine
il convient de rappeler que le V stock
est terminé que les marins russes all
pris possession et qu'ils ont ont achevé
leur formation au large de Saint nazer
où le bâtiment attend désormais de
pouvoir rejoindre sa base en Russie
quant au second navire le Sébastopol il
vient tout juste d'être mis à l'eau il
sera aménagé au cours de l'année 2015 et
doit être livré aux Russes normalement
en 2016 à l'issue de ce nouvel
ajournement si la France est décidé au
regard de ce qui se passe en Ukraine que
les conditions une livraison ne sont
toujours pas réunis pour en pour
envisager la livraison de ces deux
bâtiments nous pourrions nous exposer à
de sérieuses
difficultés contentieux long et coûteux
avec la Russie risque financiers pour
les trois entreprises concernées par ce
contrat difficulté supplémentair pour le
budget de la défense déjà
sousenstion possible fragilisation de la
parole de la France et j'ajoute des
conséquences très néfaste pour nos
exportations agricoles en direction de
la Russie dans dans ces
conditions dans ces conditions le
gouvernement peut-il nous éclairer sur
son appréciation de ce dossier informer
le Sénat sur nos échanges avec la Russie
jusqu'à quand peut-on envisager
d'ajourner la livraison enfin
pouvez-nous nous informer de la
situation en Ukraine le cesser le feu
entre Kiev et les prorusses a-t-il des
choses à terme d'être respecté mais
qu'est-ce qui sur le terrain ukrainien
pourrait permettre de débloquer le
dossier démistral merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur arlem
desésir secrétaire d'État chargé des
affaires européennes merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Jean-Claude requier je vous remercie de
cette question sur ce dossier qui ne
doit prêter à aucune polémique
s'agissant d'un contrat signé en 2011 et
sur lequel il est indispensable de
prendre en compte l'ensemble de la
situation comme vous l'avez rappelé le
président de la République a annoncé
hier qu'il avait décidé de sursoir
jusqu'à nouvel ordre à l'examen de la
demande d'autorisation nécessaire à
l'exportation du premier navire BPC
c'est une décision forte et même
exceptionnelle forte parce que nous
l'avons toujours dit la France tient à
la parole donnée et respecte ses
engagement cette décision de report
s'inédié le président de la République
l'a donc prise avec la gravité qui
convient et après en avoir pesé toutes
les conséquences le gouvernement
s'assurera évidemment de la protection
de nos intérêts industriels et des
emplois liés dans les entreprises
concernées deuxièmement c'est une
décision exceptionnelle car elle répond
à des circonstances elles-mêmes
exceptionnelles vous m'interrogez sur la
situation en Ukraine elle se détériore
les combats ne cessent pas le bilan
humain s'alourdit avec près de 1000
personnes tuées depuis le cesser le feu
du 5 septembre la situation est donc
préoccupante avec toutes les
implications de cette crise sur la
sécurité du continent européen je le dis
à ceux qui nous pressent de livrer ces
bateaux une telle décision maintenant
alors que le conflit s'aggrave
aurait-elle été responsable cette
position par cette position nous
adressons un signal clair il y a urgence
à mettre en œuvre sur le terrain les
engagements pris le 5 septembre à Minsk
et a enclenché un véritable processus
politique c'est ce que nous disent on
très nettement à la fois aux Russes et
aux Ukrainiens il faut reprendre le
chemin de la négociation enrayer la
spirale du fait accompli et de
l'affrontement respecter le cesser le
feu sous contrôle de la SCE et revenir
conformément aux accords de Minsk à un
règlement diplomatique et politique de
ce conflit dans cette affaire ce qui
doit prévaloir c'est la responsabilité
et la volonté de tout faire pour mettre
fin à ce conflit c'est la ligne de la
diplomatie française et de la diplomatie
européenne je vous remercie merci
Monsieur le Ministre la parole est à
Madame lailla ai pour le groupe
écologiste monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues une fois n'est pas
coutume en matière de pollution de l'air
je ne m'adresserai pas au ministre de
l'écologie ou de la santé mais au
ministre des Finances Monsieur Michel
Sapin un cas bienent d'être franchi le
préjudice sanitaire de la pollution de
l'air est aujourd'hui avéré mais il
semble également acquis que la pollution
de l'air représente un préjudice grave
pour notre économie et nos finance il y
a quelques jours ici même tout le monde
a reconnu le drame sanitaire que
constituait la pollution de l'air et en
particulier le desel oui tout le monde
malgré ce constat unanime et alors que
le groupe écologiste vous a proposé une
solution peu de personnes ont eu le
courage de voter pour pourtant 42 à
50000 morts prématurés chaque année en
France explosion des risques d'infarctus
d'AVC d'infection respiratoire et même
de cancer des voies aériennes des
centaines de milliers d'hospitalisations
liées à des problèmes cardiaques et
respiratoires l'urgence sanitaire pour
les Français est bien là et notamment
pour les habitants des grandes
agglomérations comme Paris et
l'île-de-fance et pourtant monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement ne prend pas
ses responsabilités fait preuve de
désenvolture manifeste face aux
conséquences de la pollution de l'air il
est vrai que la facilité de céder au
lobby le monde entier considère le
diesel comme une impasse industrielle et
l'an dernier encore la France de manière
surréaliste dans le cadre du grand
emprunt a subventionné Renault à hauteur
de 20 millions d'euros et Peugeot à
hauteur de 90 million d'euros pour le
développement des moteurs diesel
hybrides forcez de constater que seuls
les les industriels automobiles et le
gouvernement ne comprennent pas le
message oserais-je penser que vous
envisagez sérieusement par nos impôts de
développer des technologies dangereuses
pour la santé des Français le
conservatisme empêche de manière
coupable la recherche l'innovation et le
développement d'alternatives propres et
durables qui seront à non pas douter les
emplois de demain que dire des 650000
journées d'arrêts de travail par an du
fait de la pollution de l'air des des 50
milliards d'euros de la que la pollution
de l'air coûte à l'économie française
chaque année et il ne s'agit là que
d'une fourchette basse et des 7
milliards d'euros d'exonération fiscale
par an pour le diesel monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple l'état
a-t-il déjà estimé de manière certaine
le coût global de la pollution de l'air
et des pollutions chimiques dans la
négative le gouvernement pourrait-il
lancer un audit indépendant pour estimer
le préjudice financier et économique
subi par l'État les entreprises et la
société française dans son ensemble ou
saisir la Cour des comptes sur ce sujet
monsieur le ministre des Finances Michel
Sapin car c'est bien à vous que
s'adresse cette question vous feriez
acte de responsabilité et de justice
sociale et environnementale si vous
acceptez à cette demande je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Marie Leen secrétaire d'État chargé
des relations avec le
Parlement monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénateur
là la ité de l'air vous avez raison est
un enjeu sanitaire majeur en France le
coût pour la société de la pollution de
l'air extérieure a été évalué vous
l'avez rappelé à 30 milliards d'euros
dont près d'un milliard d'euros
directement supporté par le système de
soins la conférence environnemental qui
se tient en ce moment se penche
aujourd'hui et demain sur ce sujet et
bien évidemment je veux ici excuser
madame Segolen royale l'état vous le
savez agit pour améliorer la qualité de
l'air et notamment dans le projet de loi
relatif à la transition énergétique il
est prévu d'accélérer la mutation du
parc automobile vers des véhicules moins
peu loin avec un bonus porté à 10000 €
pour l'achat d'un véhicule électrique en
remplacement d'un véhicule diesel dans
les zones les plus polluées il est prévu
également de développer des
infrastructures de recharge des
véhicules électriques de renouveler les
flottes de véhicules publics par des
véhicules propres de donner enfin la
possibilité au Mair de mettre en place
des zones de circulation restreinte
réservant la circulation au véhicules
les moins polluants de mieux prendre en
compte dans ces enjeux la planification
territoriale plusieurs dispositifs de
soutien ont été mis en place par l'État
dans l'industrie des projets permettant
de réduire les émissions de polluent
atmosphériqu peuvent bénéficier de prêts
bonifiés les prêts verts gérés par BP
France dans l'agriculture le projet de
feuille de route santé environnement
prévoit de mettre en œuvre des
opérations pil de réduction des
émissions polluantes notamment avec le
concours de l'ADEM enfin pour le
remplacement d'un ancien appareil de
chauffage au bois par un appareil récent
les particuliers pourront bénéficier du
crédit d'impôt de transition énergétique
de 30 %. s'agissant de l'audit que vous
demander madame la sénateur je vous
rappelle également que vous avez la
possibilité en tant que membre de cette
assemblée de saisir la Cour des comptes
si vous jugiez utile qui est la
possibilité d'avoir un audit
supplémentaire
ministre la parole est à Madame Marie-
France Beaufils pour le groupe
communiste républicain et
citoyens merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues vous avez fait le choix
monsieur le ministre des Finances et des
comptes publices de réduire la dépense
publique pour retrouver de la croissance
dites-vous de nombreux économistes y
compris ceux de l'OCDE rappelle les
limites de cette austérité
budgétaire pour y parvenir vous avez
considéré que les dotations aux
collectivités pouvaient être réduite de
11 milliards d'euros soit 22 % de la
masse totale de ces efforts aujourd'hui
plus de 13000 conseillers conseils
communaux communautaires ont voté une
motion de l'Association des maires de
France vous rappelant l'importance de la
dépense publique locale pour la vie
économique 800000 emplois conservés ou
créés dans le privé grâce aux achats au
travaux commandés par les collectivités
territoriales c'est une estimation faite
en 2006 les collectivités plus
particulièrement les communes ont subi
le gel des dotations 4 années de suite
puis la réduction d'un milliard d'euros
en 2014 d'un milliard et demi d'euros
elles ont fait des efforts de maîtrise
de leurs dépenses de fonctionnement
elles réduisent leurs travaux ce sont
les entreprises du bâtiment et des
travaux publics qui en ressentent
immédiatement les conséquences combien
d'entre elles diminue déjà leurs
effectifs la nouvelle ponction que vous
voulez imposer aux collectivités
territoriales va maintenant toucher
directement les services à la population
et en premier lieu ce réaliser par des
emplois saisonniers ou par
l'intermédiaire d'association cela
concerne les loisirs des enfants et de
la jeunesse les activités culturelles et
sportives en premier lieu autant de
domaines qui participe à la cohésion
sociale que deviendront tous ces
salariés des chômeurs supplémentaires
les collectivités territoriales ne
peuvent pas retrouver par
l'intermédiaire de l'impôt local la
perte de croissance que vous leur
imposez c'est une dégradation de la vie
des habitants de leur pouvoir d'achat
que vous décidez ainsi cette austérité
les habitants n'en peuvent plus notre
pays en souffre quand Monsieur le
Ministre allez-vous prendre enfin en
compte les effets négatifs de ces choix
et décider de maintenir les dotations au
collectivités pour qu'elles puissent
répondre aux besoins de leur population
merci ma cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Michel Sapin ministre des
Finances et des comptes publics merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice il est bien légitime
que vous posiez une question de cette
nature puisque cette assemblée après
l'Assemblée nationale se prononce en ce
moment sur le budget de la France le
projet de loi de finance et c'est un
sujet qui vous a beaucoup occupé et au
même moment il y a le Congrès des maires
qui permet d'attirer l'attention du
Gouvernement sur des sujets qui sont des
sujets sensibles des sujets
où il est nécessaire que les uns et les
autres nous fassions des efforts dans
des conditions qui soient maîtrisé vous
le savez madame la sénatrice la France
lorsque nous sommes arrivés avait un
déficit public considérable je n'ai
personne entendu personne me dire qu'il
fallait à ce moment-là augmenter le
déficit non il faut le réduire nous le
faisons un rythme qui est un rythme que
nous considérons nous comme compatible
avec le retour de la croissance
c'est-à-dire à un rythme moindre que
celui que certains voudraient nous
imposer mais des efforts doivent être
demandés à tous d'abord bien sûr à
l'État dont le budget baisse en euros
dont le budget baisse en euros en 2014
et continuera à baisser en euros en 2015
à la sécurité sociale tout
particulièrement s'agissant des dépenses
de maladie mais aussi aux collectivités
locales on ne peut pas considérer dans
notre pays qu'un effort est à faire sur
la dépense publique sans que un effort
soit fait aussi par les collectivités
locales nous avons bien sûr conscience
de cet effort mais il est nécessaire et
ce sont ces 11 milliards sur 3 ans de
diminution des concours financiers de
l'État aux collectivités territoriales
qui manifeste cet effort demandé aux
collectivités il y a une vraie
difficulté c'est la très grande
hétérogénéité des situations entre
collectivités locales qu'il s'agisse des
régions des départements mais aussi à
l'intérieur des communes puisque c'est
principalement ce sujet qui nous
préoccupe en cet instant il y a des
dispositifs de péréquation qui déjà
tiennent compte de cette diversité mais
ces dispositifs doivent pouvoir être
améliorés je voudrais citer quelques
exemples le Fond national de péréquation
des ressources intercommunale et
communale va progresser encore en 2015
son montant aura fait plus que quintuplé
en passant de 2012 à 2015 je dis ça à
ceux dont j'entends une voix qui me
paraît peu avertie de 2002 à 2015 de 150
à 780 millions d'euros ce n'est pas eux
qui l'ont fait c'est vous enfin la MAJ
majorité ici à l'époque qui l'a voté or
le ce fond de péréquation soutient tout
particulièrement les communes rurales en
difficulté il en va de même s'agissant
des 10000 communes qui touchent la DSR
dite cible ou les 250 communes qui qui
touche la DSU dite cible pour conclure
je voudrais dire qu'il faut encore
améliorer ce dispositif de péréquation
le gouvernement le ministre du Budget
l'a annoncé ce matin est ouvert il
demande votre collaboration d'une
réforme de la DGF pour que cette DGF
soit plus justement répartie qu'il y ait
pas plus par habitant à Neï qu'à Gueret
par exemple et encore je ne cite pas
argent sur
ministre la parole est à madame Claudine
Lepage pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres chers
collègues l'existence même de la journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes célébré il y
a 2 jours révèle combien ce fléau
demeure plus que jamais
d'actualité bien sûr en France des
avancées notables ont été réalisées
permettez-moi à cet égard d'évoquer la
loi velle sur l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse dont l'examen devant les
députés débutait il y a juste 40 ans
pourtant aujourd'hui encore dans notre
pays 216000 femmes sont victimes chaque
année de violences commises par leurs
partenaires tous les 3 jours une femme
meurt sous les coups de son compagnon ou
ex-compagnon 86000 femmes indiquent
avoir été victimes de viol ou de
tentative de viol dont seul 10 % dépose
plainte madame la ministre je suis fière
de soutenir un gouvernement qui a pris
des mesures fortes pour lutter contre
les inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes et particulièrement contre le
symptôme le plus grave et inacceptable
que constituent les violences dont elles
sont victimes je salue les mesures
volontaristes prise dans le cadre du 4e
plan interministériel et également la
loi du 4 août 2014 pour l'égalité réelle
entre les femmes et les hommes le
doublement des moyens la plateforme
téléphonique d'écoute le nombre
d'intervenants sociaux dans les
commissariats et gendarmerie le
renforcement de l'ordonnance de
protection la généralisation du
téléphone grand danger sont des mesures
efficaces pour aider concrètement les
femmes la prévention et la lutte contre
les mariages forcés qui concerne 400
millions de femmes et d'enfants dans le
monde 70000 jeunes femmes en France
étant potentiellement menacé et les
mutilations sexuelles font également
l'objet d'un dispositif installé par les
ministères des droits des femmes et des
Français de l'étranger qui a mobilisé
notre réseau
consulaire mais il reste tant à faire
vous venez de signer madame la ministre
avec Bernard cas Christian tobira et
Marie Touren une convention avec la
police visant à systématiser le dépôt de
plainte des femmes victimes de violence
quelles sont les conditions
d'application et les objectifs de ce
dispositifs plus généralement quelles
autres actions seront aussi engagées je
vous remercie également de m'apporter
des précisions sur le rôle de nos postes
diplomatiques dans la lutte contre les
mariages forcés et sur la formation
dédié que reçoivent nos agents
consulaires merci
merci la parole est à Madame Pascale
Boitard secrétaire d'État chargé des
droits de femmes merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Claudine Lepage vous l'avez
rappelé des chiffres terribles 216000
femmes sont victime de violence chaque
année une femme meurt tous les 3 jours
sous les coups de de son compagnon ou
ex-compagnon et dans le cadre des
violences conjugales TR 33 enfants par
an
meurt ce sont aussi de une à 4 années
d'espérance de vie en moins pour ces
femmes qui subissent des violences et
nous avons évidemment comme vous l'avez
dit
euh pris des mesures importantes pour
justement euh contrecarrer ce
fléo 66 millions d'euros c'est le
doublement des moyens à loué à ce à ce
fléo et nous avons pris plusieurs
mesures des moyens qui sont dédiés à la
formation de l'ensemble des
professionnels à la fois du ministère de
l'intérieur de la justice des personnels
de santé mais aussi vous l'avez dit un
protocole qui a été signé déjà dans 35
départements et nous avons signé le 36e
mardi dernier avec Christian tobira
Bernard casenu et Marie soltouren qui
consiste à mettre en lien tous les
acteurs associatifs intervenants sociaux
présents sur les commissariats ou
gendarmerie il s'agit de conserver comme
priorité le dépôt de plainte mais de
déclencher dès le dépôt d'une main
courante ou procèsverbal un
accompagnement immédiat de la victime la
convocation immédiate de l'agresseur et
évidemment de protéger la victime et ses
enfants il s'agit à ce sujet notamment
de les protéger avec des hébergements
d'urgence
600 hébergements d'urgence ont déjà été
créés depuis 2013 1050 sont encore à
créer d'ici 2017 et nous avons signé
avec jeunevè fiorazo le 25 novembre
dernier aussi une convention spécifique
pour les femmes étudiantes victimes de
violence et qui pourront avoir accès en
priorité aussi au logement étudiants
pour vous dire que nous ne baissons pas
les bras bien au contraire nous
déployons de nombreux moyens mais je
souhaite m'adresser aussi aux femmes à
travers mon intervention je souhaite
leur dire que si elles n'os pas encore
franchir le pas du commissariat ou de
l'hôpital qu'elle n'hésite pas à appeler
le 3919 aussi bien pour les mariages
forcés aussi bien pour les violences
subies au quotidien car des équipes
seront auprès d'elles pour les aider à
franchir ce pas merci Madame la Ministre
la parole est à Madame pour le groupeion
desmocrates pendant UC bonjour c'est
vraiment une question solennelle que je
voudrais poser à Madame la Ministre des
autres maères pour aider le gouvernement
polynésien opéré notre redressement
économique l'Assemblée de Polynésie
française va examiner une résolution
pour obtenir réparation du plus grave
préjudice écologique faite à une
collectivité de la République après les
tirs de 193 essai nucléaire entre 1966
et 1996 sur les atols de oururua et
fangatoufa la question est d'actualité
madame la ministre à la veille de la
conférence environnementale présentée
comme une étape décisive pour obtenir
fin 2015 la signature de l'accord
historique contre les dérèglements
climatiques dont les négociations durent
depuis 20 ans sur la même période après
la prise de conscience de la gravité des
effets des expérimentations nucléaires
les défenseurs de l'environnement et des
victimes civiles ainsi que des élus de
diverses sensibilités ne cessent de
réclamer que soit reconnu et compensé
cet état de fait la résolution examinée
ce soir à papéeté refuse que la rente
nucléaire qui compense la dérégulation
économique causée par l'implantation
puis par le départ du centre
d'expérimentation nucléaire soit versé
pour solde de tout compte les
compensations financières demandées se
font sur deux principes celui du
préjudice écologique voté tout à son
honneur et à l'unanimité par le Sénat en
avril
2013 celui du pollueur payeur défendu
résolument par la ministre de l'écologie
enfin si la presse se fait l'écho
d'approche différente entre le
gouvernement et l'Assemblée pour obtenir
des crédits je témoigne ici qu'à papét
comme à Paris tous les efforts conver au
plan politique pour opérer le
redressement économique aussi alors que
la France se veut et à juste titre
exemplaire pour défendre l'environnement
de notre
planète quelles sont les garanties
quelle garantie le gouvernement peut-il
donner aux Polynésiens pour que soit
enfin reconnu indemnisé l'un des pires
préjudices écologiques infligés à un
environnement depuis la naissance de
l'humanité marourou merci ma cher
collègue la parole est à Madame George
paulevin ministre des outr
m merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Terra iriti effectivement nous
connaissons ce grave problème des essais
nucléaires dans le Pacifique et nous
avons été nombreux me semble-t-il
notamment de ce côté-là de l'hémicycle à
souhaité qu'effectivement d'une part ces
essais nucléaires s'arrêtent et par
ailleurs souhaiter que le préjudice
écologique qui a résultait soit réparé
par conséquent sur le principe je ne
vois pas de difficulté entre nous ce
qu'il faut noter cependant c'est que
cette résolution je n'ai pas pour ma
part à me prononcer sur son opportunité
puisque c'est la liberté de du
territoire et de l'assemblée que de
faire de telles demandes toutefois je
tiens quand même à rappeler que une
certaine somme
et aides spécifiques avaient été mis en
place précisément pour réparer cela et
malheureusement comme vous le savez
c'est d'abord en 2002 puis en 2008 alors
que yvj était secrétaire d'État à
l'outrem que les sommes ont été réduite
d'une manière significative toutefois il
est clair que depuis 2002 il y a environ
plus de 1 milliard d'euros 1 milliard 7
soit 204 milliards de francs pacifiques
qui ont déjà été versés vous savez aussi
que depuis que nous sommes arrivés
depuis 2012 nous travaillons de près
avec l'actuel président Fritch à
l'époque députés et les députés
minassage et tueva pour essayer de
réparer un certain nombre de préjudices
qui était posé à la Polynésie notamment
par le fait que les efforts qui avaient
été faits enfin le le financement de
l'État au régime de solidarité de la
Polynésie française avait été coupé donc
nous sommes en train de travailler pour
essayer de rétablir ces sommes qui sont
tout à fait utiles nécessaires à la
Polynésie donc je ne crois pas que
aujourd'hui ce soit totalement facile ou
en tout cas soit parulement le moment
que de relancer un autre sujet alors que
nous essayons déjà de régler des
problèmes qui sont des problèmes de fond
tout à fait important vous savez par
ailleurs que nous assurons la sécurité
de ces deux atols et que là encore
l'État assure des responsabilités qui
sont tout à fait naturelles donc voilà
actuellement nous travaillons pour
rétablir des liens et essayer de
répondre correctement aux demandes de la
Polynésie comme vous le savez ma porte
est toujours ouverte Vous avez
l'occasion de venir me voir nous pouvons
en reparler mais je crois que cette
résolution on verra quelle suite lui
apporter quand elle sera votée mais bien
évidemment compte tenu de son montant ça
demandera me semble-t-il longtemps à de
des discussions pour pouvoir arriver à
répondre à de tels montants qui sont
tout à fait stratosphériques merci
Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur jaces
jeunest pour le groupe Union pour un
mouvement
populaire merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie de
l'industrie et du numérique monsieur le
ministre dans quelques heures les
chiffres du chômage pour le mois
d'octobre seront publiés bien triste
rendez-vous pour les 3400000 chômeurs
officiels qui savent qu'ils n'ont rien à
espérer d'une politique qui signe chaque
mois son échec à ce propos la situation
des 1400000 actifs du secteur BTP est
tout à fait préoccupante en 1 an
l'emploi salarié y a baissé de 2 %
l'emploi intérimaire de presque 7 % et
pour le seul mois d'octobre de 20 %. ces
chiffres sont la conséquence d'un fait
édifiant rarement on a construit si peu
de logements en France avec seulement
300000 mise en chantier sur les 12
derniers mois et une baisse de 11,4 %
com comme on est loin des 500000 promis
par le candidat François Hollande la
conjecture ne peut seule expliquer ce
phénomène des normes toujours plus
nombreuses et des règles d'urbanisme
toujours plus rigides entrav la
construction notamment en milieu rural
les maires doivent faire face à
l'incompréhension de leurs concitoyens
qui voient de plus en plus de terrains
classés
inconstructible cette situation
contribue à tirer vers le haut le prix
du mètre carré de terrain à bâtir avec
une augmentation de 8,8 % en 2013 et ce
n'est qu'un début la loi allure
véritable usine à gaz dont même le
gouvernement reconnaît les erreurs a
enleveré toute confiance aux
investisseurs enfin je citerai la baisse
des dotations qui affectent les
collectivités territoriales alors que
ces dernières représentent environ 70 %
de l'activité des entreprises de Travaux
Public aujourd'hui le gouvernement veut
frapper encore plus drastiquement et
brutalement leurs ressources en dépit du
compromis équilibré trouvé par le Sénat
les quelques avancées présentées par le
projet de loi de finance pour 2015
n'auront que des effets très différés
dans le temps et ne suffiront pas à
amorcer le redémarrage indispensable
pour ce secteur qui est l'un des piliers
de notre croissance et qui crée des
emplois qui ne sont pas délocalisables
quand Monsieur le Ministre allez-vous
prendre des mesures urgentes qui
s'imposent pour faire repartir
l'activité et l'emploi dans la
construction merci mon cher la parole
est à madame Carole delg secrétaire
d'État chargé du commerce de l'artisanat
de la consommation et de l'économie
sociale et solidaire merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Jacques
jeunest la crise du logement pèse
lourdement sur le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens qui dépense en comparaison
de la plupart de nos voisins européens
beaucoup trop pour se loger dans de
nombreuses villes il est difficile de
trouver un logement aujourd'hui
l'urgence dans ce pays est de donner un
logement à tous les Français quelle que
soit leur situation quels que soit leurs
besoins pour y parvenir nous n'avons
d'autre choix que de construire
davantage car les problèmes du
mallogement proviennent essentiellement
d'un manque de construction nous avons
donc agi pour la relance de la
construction notamment en fluidifiant
les parcours résidentiels les
entreprises du bâtiment nous ont fait
part bien sûr je les reçois des
difficultés considérables et nous avons
mis en place un certain nombre de mes
mesure nous devons en effet poursuivre
cet objectif gouvernemental qui est
d'avoir un impact important pour la
croissance un impact positif sur
l'emploi nous avons simplifié les règles
en matière d'urbanisme encourager
l'investissement restaurer la confiance
pour relancer la construction et
permettre au ménages d'accéder au
logement je n'oublie pas non plus les
efforts de rénovation de logement car
dans la rénovation des logements il y a
un impact plus rapide que la
construction du neuf que nous avons mené
avec le crédit d'impôt développement
durable relevé à 30 %. avec bien sûr le
renforcement de l'éco PTZ VO l'encien
avec également les aides de l'ANA notre
principale priorité est bien de redonner
un élan à cette machine qui est bloqué
et qui est responsable d'une pinerie
dans les zones tendues notamment de
logement adaptés je pense également au
logement inter intermédiaire que nous
avons assoupli et encore amélioré ce
plan pour le logement bénéficiera donc à
tous les Français et c'est la raison
pour laquelle des mesures sont déjà en
place le dispositif d'investissement
locatif peut s'appliquer sur 6 9 ou 12
ans pour s'adapter aux horizons
d'investissement desménages l'abattement
exceptionnel de 30 % pour inciter à la
libération de fonciers la réforme du PTZ
et du zonage pour les adapter aux
réalités du marché immobilier et
d'autres mesures s'appliqueront dès que
le projet de loi de finances pour 2015
sera voté merci madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Daniel raou
pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la visite du président de la République
à Florange visite courageuse certain
salu et le
bilan monsieur Dallier je peux
continuer et le bilan des accord pass en
novembre
2012 nousr les c'est un bel exemple que
la réindustrialisation de notre pays est
possible on ne valorise pas assez les
réussites les réussites
industriell en effet je rappelle
quelques chiffres concernant florenge
c'est 146 des 180 millions qui était
prévu dans l'accord initial de novembre
2012 qui sont d'ors et déjà engagés et
certes on nous dit que c'est ces
investissements monteront à 240 millions
il s'agit d'une tion
technologique qui s'est faite sans
licenciement et sans plan
social on annonce même des créations
d'emploi en particulier 30 recrutement
CDI pour l'année 2015 et sans doute 30
autres à
suivre je ne mestime pas le choc
culturel de la fermeture définitive des
derniers au fourneau dans cette région
c'était des symboles tout à fait
important
d'une industrie mais regardons le succès
de la filière froide après la fermeture
de la filière liquide la production de
l'usine
uziibor a doublé en 3 ans et les carnets
de commande sont plein et
justifie justifie de dépasser les
engagements initiaux de novembre 2012
ainsi que les créations d'emploi qui
sont
annoncé ceci sécurise d'autre part la
tentation de faire des transferts
après 10 ans de désindustrialisation
qu'a connu notre pays cet exemple montre
qu'il est possible d'augmenter la part
de l'industrie dans le PIB à l'heure
actuelle cette part est descendue à 12 %
et on on considère qu'un pays voulant
jouer un rôle en tant que puissance
économique la part de son industrie ne
doit pas descendre en dessous de 20 %.
certes en incorporant les fonctions
externalisées c'est pertinemment les
effets d'obèes qu'il y a à sortir
certains secteurs de l'industrie et donc
Madame la Ministre quelle est la part en
particulier dans le cadre du Plan
Jun qui sera réservé à l'industrie
quelle est la part de l'industrie que
vous avez sélectionné dans la trentaine
de projets qui sont d'ors et déjà soumis
au jury
international voilà en
quelquci mon cher collègue la parole est
à madame Carole delg vous avez la parole
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur daniel Raoul quand nous sommes
arrivés aux responsabilités nous avons
trouvé une industrie en crise en grande
crise notre priorité depuis 2012 est de
tout d'abord mobiliser toutes les
énergies auprès des entreprisees
traversant des difficultés
conjoncturelles en la matière le
gouvernement et les commissaires
redressent productif placé auprès des
préfets n'ont rien lâché également nous
avons redonné des marges de manœuvre aux
entreprises avec le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi à ce jour 10
milliards d'euros ont été versés aux
entreprises et avec le PACT de
responsabilité ça sera 30 milliards
d'euros supplémentaire pour
l'investissement pour l'innovation et
pour l'emploi nous irons au bout de cet
engagement en ce qui concerne Florange
comme vous le signiez justement monsieur
le sénateur presque 2 ans après la
signature de l'accord et bien nous avons
un bil an qui est favorable Florange a
pleinement bénéficié du programme des
investissements qui l'ont repositionné
comme un site majeur dans le dispositif
industriel d'Arcelor mitthal dans sa
division Europe du Nord l'arrêt de la
filière liquide concernait 630 emplois
le processus de reclassement du
personnel a été achevé sans aucun
licenciement par ailleurs la direction a
annoncé l'embauche je vous le confirme
de 30 CDD d'ici la fin de l'année en
matière de RD d'ici la fin de l'année
c'est 30 CDD et pour 2015 c'est après 30
CDI en matière de RD le groupe s'est
engagé à poursuivre la recherche pour le
développement d'une technologie de
production d'acier faiblement émettrice
de CO2 nous y serons attentifs nous
avons géré l'urgence notre priorité est
aujourd'hui d'utiliser ces marges pour
démontrer que la France est une grande
nation industrielle qui se réinvente et
je voudrais dire ici que nous Français
nous n'avons pas à rougir de notre
industrie dans des domaines aussi divers
que l'aéronautique que le luxe que la
ville durable que les objets connectés
nous disposons de champions du monde que
nous en nous en Vions nous avons aussi
développé la fringchtech avec axels le
maire vous nous interrogez sur les
projets portés par notre pays dans le
cadre du plan d'investissement européen
comme tous les États-membres la France a
bien sûr élaboré une première liste de
projets qui pourrait démarrer rapidement
dans le cadre du plan dont Jean-Claude
Junker a présenté hier les orientations
il était important de lister les grandes
thématiques ce seront la transition
énergétique la Recherche et Innovation
la formation le numérique et bien
entendu les infrastructures au sein de
ces priorité la modernisation de notre
industrie est évidemment centrale nous
avons aussi bien entendu souhaité dans
le cadre de des 34 plans industriels là
aussi préparé l'avenir vous le voyez
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
ne manquons pas de courage de
détermination et de
conviction merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Pierre Charon pour
le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des Affaires
étrangères AIA bibi est une jeune
chrétienne pakistanaise condamnée à mort
pour blasphème contre le
Prophète ce qu'elle a toujours nié aabbi
P le prix de ses convictions qu'elle ne
veut pas renir
la vérité nous oblige à reconnaître que
le crime d'azabibi c'est tout simplement
sa foi chrétienne et rien d'autre son
cas illustre à lui seul les différentes
persécutions que subissent les chrétiens
dans certains pays où il ne fait pas bon
appartenir à une minorité religieuses
asabbi est tout simplement un bou
émissèire dans les sociétés guidées par
les démons du rejet et de l'intolérance
elle témoignne de ce calvaire permanent
enduré par des millions de chrétiens en
Irak en Syrie au Pakistan où s vit la
nouvelle barbarie du 21e siècle
l'affaire est si sensible au Pakistan
que certains n'osent plus défendre
aabibi un gouverneur de province et un
ministre ont même été assassiné parce
qu'ils avaient pris fê et cause pour la
jeune crétienne la justice pakistanaise
redoutant la vindicte des foules et la
violence des fanatiques préfère faire
profil bas quitte à piétiner les
principes fondamentaux du droit
emprisonné depuis 9 aabbi a été condamné
à mort en novembre 2010 la Haute cour de
la a confirmé le 16 octobre dernier 7
condamnation à mort un recours a été
déposé devant la Cour suprême le 24
novembre
2014 de nombreuses mobilisations ont eu
lieu aussi bien en France que dans le
monde entier des pétitions ont été
signées des élus sont montés au créneau
la diplomatie doit aussi montrer son
courage dans ces questions et ne pas se
retrancher derrière la prudence quand la
prudence est partout le courage n'est
nulle part la France doit faire
comprendre au Pakistan que l'exécution
d'asabbi serait un affront à tout ce que
nous avons de plus cher et qui va bien
au-delà de nos intérêts matériels
n'ayons pas peur de demander au
président pakistanais d'intervenir comme
l'a demandé le président Bruno retaillot
au président de la République française
asiaabbi doit échapper à la peine de
mort et retrouver sa liberté son honneur
de croyante de F de mère de famille je
vous demande monsieur le ministre de
nous dire ce que la France envisage pour
mettre fin à cette situation iniique et
honteuse merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur arlem desésir
secrétaire d'État chargé des affaires
européennes merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Pierre Charon la
situation d'asiabibi pakistanaise de
confession chrétiennes condamné à mort
pour blasphème nous révolte depuis la
première condamnation d'aziabibi en 2010
la France a constamment rappelé que la
notion de délit de blasphème était
contraire au principe des droits de
l'homme la France a également rappelé
son opposition à la peine de mort en
tout lieu et en toutes circonstances la
France est très attachée au respect des
libertés fondamentales au titre
desquelles la liberté de religion
liberté de conviction liberté
d'expression qui sont protégés par des
traités internationaux ceci garantisent
en particulier le droit d'exprimer ses
opinions et de manifester sa religion
ces libertés sont définies en
particulier par la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et le Pacte
international sur les droits civils et
politiques que le Pakistan a ratifié en
juin 2010 la France protège les
minorités religieuses et en particulier
les minorités chrétiennes qui sont
aujourd'hui menacées dans plusieurs pays
concernant la situation d'asiabibi de
nombreuses démarches ont été effectuées
depuis 4 ans à tous les niveaux en lien
avec nos partenaires européens mais
comme vous venez de le rappeler monsieur
le sénateur la Haute cour de Laor saisie
en 2uxe instance a confirmé le 16
octobre dernier la condamnation à mort
d'asiabibi pour délit de blasphème dès
le lendemain du verdict la France a fait
part de sa profonde préoccupation et
appelé une nouvelle fois le Pakistan à
respecter ses engagements internationaux
le président de la République est
intervenu personnellement auprès de son
homologue pakistanais pour plaider la
cause d'asiabbi au niveau européen la
Haute représentante a également exprimé
sa grande inquiétude et Espérit recours
rapide auprès de la Cour suprême
asiaabbi vient de faire appel de ce
verdict devant la Cour suprême dans ce
cadre le gouvernement français fait et
fera tout ce qui est en son pouvoir pour
qu'un dénouement positif puisse
intervenir le plus tôt possible je vous
le redis avec netteté et sans aucune
prudence la condamnation à mort
d'aziabibi pour blasphème est révoltante
inhumaine et inacceptable c'est la
position de la France nous appelons la
communauté internationale à se mobiliser
avec la France et l'Union européenne
pour faire annuler cette sentence et
pour faire annuler une condamnation
fondée sur le blasphème car nous ne
l'acceptons ni au Pakistan ni ailleurs
dans le monde et nous ferons tout pour
sauver
asiaabbi merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jacques cornano
pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues un
quotidien titre ce matin à venir des
enfant la grande inquiétude c'est 69 %
des parents qui estimeraient que
l'éducation nationale ne garantit plus
l'égalité des chances notre système
scolaire a été particulièrement
maltraité fortement dégradé cette
dernière décenni si bien qu'il figure
désormais parmi les plus
inégalitaires c'est pourquoi le
président de la République a fait de
l'éducation et de la jeunesse sa
priorité notamment en redonnant tous les
moyens nécessaires à éducation nationale
et la formation après des années de
désengagement de l'État depuis 2012 nous
créons 60000 postes nous reconstruisons
la formation professionnelle des
enseignants cette politique portera des
fruits sur les jeunes génération c'est
une politique d'avenir mais il existe
une urgence en matière éducative celle
du décochage scolaire les chiffres du
décochage sont en effet
alarmants 140000 jeunes quittent chaque
année le système scolaire sans diplôme
sans possibilité de faire valoir une
formation ces jeunes sont alors livrés à
eux-mêmes car comment peuvent-ils entrer
dans la vie active sans qualification
c'est ce drame qui doit nous préoccuper
aujourd'hui en trouvant une solution
pour ces jeunes madame la ministre vous
venez récemment de faire des annonces
fortes pour lutter contre le décochage
scolaire les moyens débloqués sont
importants mais au-delà des chiffres
c'est l'action qui est essentielle
l'orientation le suivi individualisé des
parcours la formation des enseignants
pour mieux repérer les signes
avantcoureur c'est en mobilisant tous
les acteurs que nous ferons réussir tous
les jeunes car c'est la responsabilité
de la nation tout entière de former ces
jeunes que chacun ait les moyens de
réussir ainsi pouvez-vous nous expliquer
en quoi les réponses apportées contre le
décochage scolaire dans le cadre de ce
plan ambitieux son ouvatrice merci merci
mon cher collègue la parole est à Madame
jeuneviève fiarasso secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'enseignement supérieur et de
la Recherche merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Jacques
cornano 140000 jeunes en effet sortent
chaque année du système scolaire sans
qualification ni emploi sans sans
diplôme évidemment le plan de lutte
contre le décrochage présenté vendredi
dernier
par le Premier ministre manuel Vals et
Najat Valo Belkassem dont je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence puisqu'elle est
contrainte dans d'autres lieux donc je
disais ce plan met en place une méthode
à la fois globale et individualisée qui
est composé de mesures nouvelles mais
aussi qui coordonne des mesures déjà
existantes et éprouvées il met l'accent
tout d'abord pour la première fois sur
la prévention jusqu'à présent 85 % des
moyens utilisés pour lutter contre le
décrochage était consacré à
l'intervention après le décrochage la
prévention a montré son
efficacité au Québec ou ou en Finlande
des pays qui ont un taux de réussite
scolaire extrêmement élevé après avoir
connu également des politiques de
réussite scolaire avec des taux beaucoup
moins élevés nous nous sommes donc
inspirés de ces expériences réussies de
ces bonnes pratiques et de l'évaluation
également des politiques publiques qui
ont été menées dans notre pays nous
avons mobilisé des moyens importants 300
millions d'euros soit 50 millions
d'euros par an pendant 6 ans ces crédits
regroupent des fonds européens
initiative européenne pour la jeunesse
et fonds sociau sociaux européens ainsi
que des crédits budgétaires du ministère
et et du plan des Investissements
d'Avenir ces moyens financiers
témoignent de la priorité donnée à
l'éducation et à la jeunesse par ce
gouvernement ce plan repose sur trois
réponses différent et complémentaire le
premier la première réponse c'est une
réponse simple coordonnée et surtout qui
part des besoins exprimé par les jeunes
et par les familles ça n'est pas imposé
par le haut on part pour la première
fois réellement des besoins du
terrain ce plan simple prévoit un numéro
unique et gratuit opérationnel dès
aujourd'hui pour conseiller les élèves
et les familles qui sont désorientés des
outils d'échange avec les parents comme
la malette des parents au moment clé que
sont l'entrre en 6e et l'orientation en
3e pour que les familles quel que soit
leur niveau socioculturel quel que soit
leur environnement et leur réseau de
connaissance puissent être informer et
choisir en associant mieux les parents
en associant les enfants en les
informant on réduit le risque de
décrochage une semaine de la de la
persévérance scolaire organisée chaque
année au moment des pics de décrochage
on agit aussi vous l'avez dit sur la
formation des enseignants car la
meilleure arme de lutte contre l'échec
scolaire c'est la qualité de la
formation des enseignants à qui on a
redonné une formation
professionnalisante sur le terrain alors
qu'elle avait été supprimée dans le
quinquena précédent vous le voyez nous
refusons nous refusons la fatalité du
nous refusons la fatalité du décrochage
et nous voulons donner une seconde
chance aux jeunes quel que soit leur
territoire quel que soit leur milieu
d'origine merci la parole est à Monsieur
François bonhomme pour le groupe Union
pour un mouvement
populaire monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la décentralisation et de
la fonction publique elle porte sur les
conséquences de la diminution sans
précédent des dotations de l'État aux
collectivités madame la ministre le
gouvernement veut en effet imposer au
budget des collectivités une diminution
de la ressources de 11 milliards d'euros
de 2015 à 2017 don 3,7 milliards dès
2015 cette décision va inévitablement
peser sur leurs finances prise à la
gorge les collectivités vont se
retrouver dans une position
intenable soit
contraint de procéder arbitrages
douloureux affectant les services
publics et investissements locaux que
vous affirmez par ailleurs soutenir que
dire alors des conséquences également
sur les entreprises qui vivent fortement
de la commande publique soit les élus
locaux seront contraain d'augmenter les
taux
d'imposition pourtant monsieur le
ministre vous le savez la plupart des
maires sont des personnes responsables
et acceptte de participer à l'effort
national oui un effort partagé mais
encore faut-il qu'il puisse le faire
selon une trajectoire crédible et
réaliste compte tenu de la rigidité de
leurs dépenses les collectivités ne
pourront s'adapter dans le temps à la
brutalité avec laquelle les dotations
sont réduites tout cela ne peut se faire
sans véritable étude d'impact tous les
rapports a commencé par celui de nos
collègues Philippe Dall Charles g et
Jacques mzard toutes les études de le
Martel et confirme cette sombre
perspective vous pouriez par ailleurs
inspiré utilement de l'analyse de
françois Barouin que nous saluons comme
nouveau président de l'association des
Maes de
France et qui estime je cite que le choc
sera brutal avec 30 % à moins
d'investissement public dans les TR
prochaines années et 10 % en moins
d'investissement local soit l'équivalent
de 0,2 % de point de
croissance vous pourriez également
écouter la mise en garde du président du
Comité des finances loc André lenniel
qui vient déclarer je
cite que le gouvernement sera obligé
d'arrêter de couper les dotations parce
que le traumatisme sera tel qu'il faudra
prendre des mesures de
relance effec effet ressive garantie
donc dès lors madame la ministre ma
question est la suivante allez-vous
enfin écouter les îlux locaux et
accepter une véritable négociation avec
le représentant afin de trouver ce point
d'équilibre nécessaire tant pour les
collectivités que pour notre pays merci
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Marie Leen secrétaire
d'État chargé des relations avec le
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
monsieurs les sénateurs mesdames les
sénatrice monsieur le sénateur je sais
que vous partagez la préoccupation du
gouvernement de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques non seulement vous les
partagez mais si j'écoute les
responsables de votre parti vous
souhaitez multiplier par de trouver 100
milliards et pas 50 milliards d'économie
et j'ai du peine j'ai peine à croire
j'ai peine à croire je le dis très
sincèrement et je pense ici que tout le
monde a peine à croire que vous pourriez
faire 100 milliards d'économies sans
toucher à la dotation global de
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales j'ai même la faiblesse de
penser que l'effort que vous demanderiez
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau de la justice
de l'équité et du bon fonctionnement de
l'État je pense que même l'effort que
vous demanderiez sera très nettement
supérieur et d'ailleurs le candidat que
vous avez soutenu à l'élection
présidentielle demandit dès 2012 qu'il y
ait une suppression de 10 milliards
d'euros dans la DGF au direction des
collectivités
territoriales
alors
puisque puisque puisque vous
m'interrogez monsieur le sénateur je
voudrais rentrer maintenant dans les
détails pour essayer de faire en sorte
que vous soyez rassuré sur les
conséquences de cet effort qui est
demandé qui qui est c'est un effort
difficile nous le concevons mais qu'il
est demandé évidemment à à tous d'abord
vous le savez vous avez vous l'avez
souligné c'est 11 milliards d'euros qui
sont demandés sur les 3 ans qui viennent
c'est un effort que nous considérons
comme équitable par rapport aux autres
acteurs public car il correspond au
poids de leur dépenses dans la dépense
publique qui est de 21 % au poids de la
dépense publique monsieur le sénateur
cet eff représente en moyenne 1,6 % des
recettes totales des collectivités
teritorial pour domicel ce n'est pas
nutre c'est un effort mais ce n'est pas
non plus je crois l'étranglement que
parfois j'entends décrire ici ou là en
outre ces collectivités les plus
fragiles seront très largement
préservées grâce au renforcement de la
péréquation évidemment et sur ces
éléments bien évidemment vous serez très
attentif pour un certain nombre de
départements que je connais dans la
région parisienne qui sont n'est-ce pas
monsieur garucci très sensibles au aux
questions de péréquation enfin les
recettes globales des collectivités
devraient continuer à croître en 2015
notamment grâce à la revalorisation des
bases fiscales notamment car grâce à
l'évolution positive de la CVAE vous
avez noté également les mesures prises
que en faveur du FCTVA qui consiste à
supprimer la réfaction de 09 points et
donc et surtout sortir de l'enveloppe
normée
l'augmentation 2 15 du FCTVA cela
représentera près de 200 millions
d'euros soit 70 car nous savons que 70 %
de l'investissement local est porté par
le bloc communal enfin la revalorisation
du barè de la taxe de séjour
correspondra il faut donc porter un
regard global sur l'ensemble de ces
mesures pour quantifier la baisse des
ressources des collectivités territorial
voilà monsieur le sénateur les
informations que je pouvez apporter à
votre connaissance merci monsieur le
ministre avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement après avoir
et voilà donc pour ces questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement cet
après-midi au Sénat on se retrouve tout
de suite avec nos invités pour refaire
ensemble la
séance